okay the World Cup starts this week and
I am both excited and extremely
conflicted about it now I know in
America soccer is something you pick
your ten-year-old daughter up from but
for me and everyone else on earth it's a
little more important
soccer had become d'azyr's religion in
Colombia soccer was a religion football
is a religion here soccer or football
like we say it's a religion and they're
not exaggerating when David Beckham got
a tattoo of Jesus the response of most
soccer fans was that that's huge for
Jesus that's a big deal for him here's
here's my conflict the World Cup is one
of my favorite things but it's organized
by these guys
FIFA you either know it as the
fédération Internationale de Football
Association or that soccer video game
you have but for American viewers who
may never have encountered them FIFA is
a comically grotesque organization in
fact telling someone about the inner
workings of FIFA for the first time it's
a bit like showing someone two girls one
cup yeah you do it mainly so you can
watch the horrified expression on
people's faces